♪ ♪
(cheering and applause)
All right.
Thank you.
Thank you very much. Uh...
Thank you very much.
Now, I'm gonna be doing,
uh, some magic.
So I have some witnesses here
to, uh, keep me honest.
-(cheering and applause)
-Uh, thank you, witnesses.
And, uh, now...
Oh, I have to mention,
the last time we did this,
there was some, um...
(sighs) so-called... It's
called black reacting. Um...
Look, for those of you
that don't know what that is,
well, black people
are a bit suspect of magic,
and they tend to, what
scientists call, black react.
Okay? This is a true term.
Uh, here's an example of it
happening to David Blaine.
-(laughter)
-Open.
-Open it.
-(shouting, laughter)
It's true. What happened?
Okay, so this time,
I'm giving you fair warning.
You guys black reacted
last time. But this time,
-remain calm, okay? -All right.
-Okay. -Okay, okay. No problem.
-I do not actually have magical
powers, okay? -Okay. All right.
This is only a demonstration. No
need to be alarmed, all right?
-We got you. We got it,
we got it. -Okay. -Yeah.
-We're just gonna be calm.
-That's us. That's us, man.
Okay. All right. Okay, guys,
let's imagine, uh,
these aces represent actors.
Okay? Uh, I'm gonna show
you guys the power of focus.
-Rory, can you hold out
your, uh... -Yeah, of course.
your hand there? Okay.
Uh, I'm just gonna ask you
a couple questions, Rory.
They're very simple, okay?
-What is the color of this ace?
-Uh, it's black.
Wrong. African-American. That's
okay, Rory. Take your time.
-Sorry. I'm sorry. -It's okay.
It's my fault. My fault.
I know. It's my fault.
I should have been more clear.
Okay, what is the... what
is the suit of this card, Rory?
And keep in mind I'm just
a little sensitive right now,
so I'd be care...
No, it's a joke. It's a joke.
It's a horrible joke.
Okay, Rory, but here's
the trick question.
Here's the trick question, Rory.
Which ace
should be on top? The ace
of spades or the ace of clubs?
It's a trick question.
Which ace should be on top,
-the ace of spades or the ace
of clubs? -Ace of clubs.
Okay. See, you're really focused
on black right now, aren't you?
-Yeah. Yeah, I... Yeah.
-I know. That's why it's...
-But, see, the Academy isn't.
-No! -(indistinct shouting)
-What the (bleep)?! -Guys...
-(indistinct shouting)
Guys... Guys, no...
What are you doing?
Get the (bleep) out of here!
-Stop it. Guys.
-Get the (bleep) out of here!
-Okay, guys, calm down. Calm
down. -What the (bleep) is that?
-You don't need to react... It's
not real magic. -What happened,
-Rory?! What the (bleep)?! Get
out of here! -It's just a trick.
-Come on! Get the (bleep) out
of here! -Mike. Okay. Mike...
Guys... Mike...
This-this is a rare strain
of black reacting.
He's the... he's the
aggressive insulter. It'll pass.
-No, no, no! You're a (bleep)
witch, Larry! -No. Calm down,
-Mike. Mike, calm down. It's me.
-No, you're a witch! No,
-listen... -It's Larry. It's
Larry. It's Larry. It's Larry.
-It's me. No, no. It's Larry.
It's me, Mike. -But it was r...
It's okay. It's okay. Yeah.
-Okay. Good? Okay. All right.
-All right. Okay. Okay.
-He's good. Yeah. -I'm just
saying, it was black and then...
-I know. I know. Okay.
It's okay. -Okay. -Whew.
-Okay, are we all back?
Okay. Okay. -Can I...
-Yeah. I think so. We tried,
but... -We got it, we got it.
-Are you guys gonna be...
Can I do this? -Yeah. Yeah.
-You're gonna be okay?
You're not gonna react? -Yeah.
-'Cause I'll just leave.
-Just... No, no, no, no.
Okay. All right.
(sighs) Okay. All right.
Take a look, guys.
This is Hollywood racism
we're talking about, okay?
And Academy voters aren't
just like any old magicians.
They're practically Doug
Henning. Google him, bitches.
(chuckles)
Here, I'll-I'll show you, okay?
Let's say that these cards
are people of all stripes
who have given
great performances this year.
They could've been Latino,
they could've been black,
they could've been Asian.
They could've been
any people of color.
All of these people
are people that could have been,
uh, performing this year.
But once the Oscars get mixed
into it, boom...
-Mm-mm. Mm-mm. Uh-uh.
-Oh... now.
-White. White. -Uh-uh. -No, no,
no, no! -(indistinct shouting)
White. Now, look, that...
that...
-This is what I thought. This is
what I thought. -Come on, man!
-No... W... -What are you
doin'?! What are you...
How'd you do that?! How
the (bleep) you'd do that?!
She's giving her CPR.
-(shouting) -I can't take it!
I can't take it, Larry!
The Academy members are covered
in cobwebs,
and spiders crawl out
of their eye sockets!
But those witches
are so powerful
because they made a pact
to never reveal their secrets!
-I told you he was the devil!
-Damn, Mike, stop it!
-We'll be right back!
Oh, thank you. -God help me!
(cheering and applause)